y
[Música]
se mantienen los enfrentamientos entre
israel y el grupo hamas en la franja de
gaza el primer ministro israelí benyamín
netanyahu indicó que no tiene un plazo
para poner fin a las incursiones
militares lo que genera temor en la
comunidad internacional por una posible
conflicto de larga duración los ataques
dejan hasta ahora 227 palestinos y 12
israelíes fallecidos
cuarta jornada de paro nacional y
vigésima segunda jornada de
manifestaciones ciudadanas en colombia
que transcurren hasta ahora en total
calma pero con bloqueos que han generado
complicaciones en el abastecimiento de
algunas regiones los promotores del paro
y el gobierno de colombia mantienen
negociaciones sin avanzar en un acuerdo
tenemos reporte desde bogotá
y con la apertura de bares en
restaurantes centros culturales y
también una reducción en el 'toque de
queda' francia recuperó la tan añorada
normalidad de cara al verano boreal
tenemos información desde parís la
capital francesa
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 vamos a comenzar
en medio oriente allí en el décimo día
de la escalada militar continúan los
enfrentamientos en la franja de gaza ya
son 227 los palestinos fallecidos
mientras que del lado israelí las
víctimas mortales ascienden a 12 en la
jornada de hoy israel denunció el
lanzamiento de cuatro cohetes desde
territorio libanés hacia el norte de
israel mientras tanto persiste la
presión de la comunidad internacional
que pide poner fin a la violencia el
primer ministro de israel benjamin
netanyahu respondió al pedido del
presidente de eeuu yobái dende desee
escalar la violencia en gaza de manera
inmediata indicó que mantendrá su
operación militar hasta tanto no alcance
su meta y restaure la calma para los
israelíes marina sardina nos cuenta más
en el siguiente informe
sin tregua en el intercambio de ataques
entre las fuerzas israelíes y el grupo
islamista hamás el primer ministro de
israel benjamin netanyahu aseguró que
para los llamados internacionales no
tiene un plazo previsto para acabar con
la actual escalada bélica sobre el
sitiado enclave de la franja de gaza
sólo hay dos formas en que puede
escribir con ellos puedes conquistar los
ies es siempre una posibilidad abierta o
puedes disuadirlos y estamos
comprometidos en este momento en una
disuasión contundente pero debo decir
que no descartamos hacer cualquier cosa
para restaurar la tranquilidad
esperamos poder restaurarla rápidamente
quiero decir que lo estamos haciendo al
mismo tiempo que hacemos todo lo posible
para evitar víctimas civiles el
estruendo de los ataques aéreos
israelíes volvió a sacudir zonas
residenciales de gaza durante la
madrugada del miércoles cuando las
hostilidades entraron en su décima
jornada
lo que el estado de ocupación está
haciendo ahora en la franja de gaza
antes de los monstruosos ataques contra
civiles y los ataques deliberados contra
casas y edificios sobre las cabezas de
sus residentes y la destrucción de
infraestructuras
sin hato de niños ancianos y mujeres se
considera un terrorismo de estado
organizado que el estado de ocupación
israelí está practicando
en la franja de gaza- los daños
materiales por los ataques tendrían un
costo de 250 millones de dólares según
las autoridades palestinas más de 72 mil
civiles han huido de sus hogares y se
están refugiando en escuelas y edificios
de naciones unidas la onu ha pedido a
israel la apertura de los corredores
humanitarios
pedimos una pausa humanitaria para
permitir la distribución de ayuda
humanitaria de emergencia preparaciones
de emergencia de la infraestructura
esencial para que las familias compren
alimentos y agua busquen atención médica
y atiendan otras necesidades básicas
desde el estallido de la escalada el
pasado 10 de mayo han muerto más de 200
palestinos entre ellos más de 60 niños y
12 personas de israel'
cuarta jornada de paro nacional en
colombia y vigésimo segundo día de
movilizaciones sociales varias calles y
plazas de bogotá y de otras ciudades del
país fueron el punto de concentración de
ciudadanos que de manera pacífica siguen
reclamando mejores políticas económicas
y sociales al gobierno del presidente
iván duque mientras tanto los promotores
del paro y también el gobierno
colombiano siguen en negociaciones sin
alcanzar un acuerdo mientras tanto los
comerciantes comienzan a sentir las
millonarias pérdidas por los bloqueos y
los cierres de las principales
carreteras del país vamos a conversar
con luís muñoz periodista de france 24
quien se encuentra en el norte de bogotá
en el sector conocido como los héroes en
donde se calcula que unas 2.000 personas
se han congregado allí para esta jornada
de paro
lluís que tal transcurrió el desarrollo
de esta cuarta jornada de paro hubo
también ya lo decíamos bloqueos en
algunas de las vías de las regiones
incluso hasta uno de los líderes de la
de la oposición salió en estas marchas
buenas noches santi desde el monumento a
los héroes como puedes ver el clima el
ambiente es tranquilo es incluso festivo
y es un clima que ha regido en los otros
puntos de concentración que hay en
bogotá y que también han dominado todo
el país que a destacar que esta es la
tercera semana de protestas en el país y
como comentabas la nota
señalada aquí en bogotá ha sido la
presencia en las calles del senador de
izquierda y candidato a la presidencia
gustavo petro quien el día de ayer había
llamado a los colombianos a salir a las
calles también en el día de ayer se
conoció que el director ejecutivo de
human rights watch josé miguel vivanco
anunció que habían tenido denuncias de
al menos 55 muertes desde el inicio de
las protestas y el lunes el presidente
iván duque anunció el despliegue máximo
de fuerza pública para detener el
desabastecimiento que está generando los
bloqueos que hay por distintas vías de
todo el país y que como comentaba están
generando también pérdidas millonarias
para los empresarios en la jornada de
hoy uno de los departamentos más
afectados es risaralda en el occidente
colombiano por el bloqueo de las vías
lluís tampoco prosperó en la jornada de
hoy en la cámara de representantes- esa
propuesta de una reforma a la salud en
colombia pudo
entonces la presión social porque era
también uno de los grandes reclamos de
estas movilizaciones ciudadanas
desde que iniciase en las protestas el
28 de abril ya ha caído una reforma
tributaria ha caído un ministro de
hacienda la canciller y hoy la reforma
de la salud en el congreso los
manifestantes han considerado que esto
es una victoria de las calles de la
presión social de las protestas que está
viviendo el país desde hace tres semanas
sin embargo también ahora se entra en
una nueva fase en un nuevo contrato
social en las negociaciones entre el
gobierno de iván duque pone el comité
nacional de paro sigan nuestras
negociaciones para los jóvenes para
muchos manifestantes aquí concentrados
no son válidas ya que ellos exigen que
para poder empezar a hablar el gobierno
tendría que el gobierno tendría que
condenar completamente la violencia
policial ya que consideran que han
vivido desde el inicio 22 días de
manifestaciones ciudadanas cumples ya
colombia muchas gracias luis por este
reporte desde el norte de bogotá
cambiamos de información francia
recuperó la tan añorada normalidad con
la apertura de bares restaurantes
centros culturales y también una
reducción del toque de queda que ahora
comenzará a partir de las 9 de la noche
esta fase de arte
se extenderá hasta el 9 de junio fecha
en la que también van a reabrir los
gimnasios esto coincide con el anuncio
de la unión europea de tener una
apertura a los turistas que tengan las
dos dosis de las vacunas y que provengan
de países que estén en una condición
sanitaria estable fuera de las fronteras
de la unión europea
natalia ruiz desde parís la capital
francesa nos da más detalles de esta
apertura para la sociedad francesa
tuvieron que pasar cerca de siete meses
para que los franceses pudieran regresar
al teatro aquí estalló el teatro
nacional de la danza fue una de las
primeras salas en parís en volver a
abrir sus puertas y durante todo este
mes de mayo estará ofreciendo
espectáculos gratuitos hablamos con
algunos de los espectadores de las
personas que vinieron a este teatro y
nos contaron que se sentía estar de
regreso me siento muy muy orgullosa de
estar aquí es mi primera salida obvia
hawks y frustración desde hace un año
nos tienen cansados con esas
restricciones estoy contento de poder
salir gran parte de los cafés y
restaurantes de la capital también
volvieron a abrir sus puertas el dueño
de este restaurante nos contó cómo se
preparó para la reapertura y sabe que
usamos circuitos muy cortos con
productos que vienen directamente de
bretaña algunos habían dejado de
trabajar por eso queríamos estar seguros
de que tendríamos los productos esa era
una primera preocupación y la segunda
era saber si los clientes regresarían
porque entre la segunda ola y la
vacunación que avanzaba lento estábamos
preocupados temíamos que la gente dejara
de venir que tan chicos
[Música]
y hay mucha expectativa de todos los
sectores del país esperando que haya una
verdadera reactivación de la economía la
siguiente etapa clave será a partir del
9 de junio cuando comience la segunda
parte de este nuevo del confinamiento y
continúa la crisis diplomática entre
españa y marruecos luego de que en los
últimos dos días cerca de ocho mil
migrantes ingresaron de manera irregular
al ex clave español de ceuta ubicado en
la costa norteafricana nuevamente un
flujo constante de emigrantes intentó
nadar hasta este territorio en la
jornada de hoy ya cerca de 5000 de ellos
fueron enviados de regreso a territorio
marroquí
y así llegamos al final de las noticias
aquí en france24 recuerde que cada 30
minutos tenemos una actualización con
las principales noticias de la jornada
siga con nuestra programación muy buenas
noches para todos
[Música]